-Switching gears, you guys,
here's some great news.
After 118 days,
the Screen Actors Guild
reached a deal
with the Hollywood studios.
The strike is over!
[ Cheers and applause ]
So tune in tomorrow
when my guests will be everyone.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, interesting that the...
[ Cheers and applause ]
The guys from Please
Don't Destroy.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome.
What are you guys doing here?
Shouldn't you be up at "SNL"?
-Dude, I'll tell you
what we're doing here.
-What?
-We were on the show
three days ago,
and we couldn't talk about our
movie because the actors strike.
-Yeah, but now it's over
and we can talk about it.
So why don't you book us?
-What do you mean,
why don't we book you?
You were just here.
-Yeah, but we weren't able
to talk about our movie.
"Please Don't Destroy:
The Treasure of Foggy Mountain"
coming out on Peacock.
-Yeah, well...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, you come back
and you can talk about it.
-Who do you have booked tonight?
-We're fully booked.
We have Jared Leto
on the show tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, what movie
does he have coming out?
-He's not talking
about a movie.
He's announcing a world tour
with 30 Seconds to Mars.
-So he's not talking about
"Please Don't Destroy:
The Treasure of Foggy Mountain"
coming out
November 17th on Peacock?
-No, he's not talking about it.
-Oh, okay.
-Okay. Who else is on the show?
-AJR is on the show tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah.
So AJR is going to talk about
"Please Don't Destroy:
The Treasure of Foggy Mountain"
coming out on peacock.com
November 17th?
You can sign up today.
-Uh, no, AJR is not going to
talk about that at all.
They're a great band
and they have a new album
coming out tonight
at midnight actually.
Tonight. Yeah.
-Wow. So then...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, I just don't understand
how the hell anyone
is going to find out about
"Please Don't Destroy:
The Treasure of Foggy Mountain,"
which is coming out
November 17th on Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I don't know
how that's going to happen.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to let you down.
-Okay. Alright. We're going
to go do "Seth." Um...
-Wow.
-Before we leave,
we just want to say
this audience is
the best audience in the world!
-Get out of here!
-Love you, Jimmy.
-Bye, guys.
Get out of here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Get out of here.
Please Don't Destroy.